first of all obviously when you're going
to cut costs start with data which
businesses are underperforming which
product lines are underperforming which
people are underperforming and you know
start there what I think often happens
is the company's hope for some natural
process of attrition things start to get
difficult they kind of take
across-the-board cuts and that's almost
never a good idea I remember just
recently I was having a conversation
with a CFO and a large company and they
had just kinda had kind of a blanket
policy that every division every
national organization was going to have
to take down headcount by ten percent
and I said like this is across the board
no exceptions no exceptions everybody
has to do it as a mandate I said well
surely that can't be the right way to do
it I said you know you have divisions
that have great growth prospects you
have others that are going fat and lazy
why you know why just do it across the
board and he said because it's fair I
said how is that fair i mean you know
some some businesses already lean some
isn't how can that possibly be fair he
thought him and he said yeah you're
right but it's easy well easy is usually
not a good criteria for making a
business decision so the starting
approach for any kind of smart
cost-cutting is really a very very
careful analysis of what's grown fat
what's going lady where do we have great
prospects where do we don't but
cost-cutting should never be uniform and
across the board number one
number two I think in smart cost-cutting
you spend a lot of time talking to
people about what's happening you know
clearly some people are going to have to
go and how do you avoid demoralizing all
the folks that are left well first you
have to be honest about what's changing
in the environment that's not too hard
at the moment most people get that we're
in a very very deep recession but you
also have to be be kind of have a due
process and make sure that in the heat
of trying to bring your costs back in
line you're not indiscriminate and how
you let people go that you're taking
people one at a time you're really
evaluating their contribution they
understand why it's that person and not
the person next door to them that is
being asked to leave and when you have
to cut deep enough so you feel that
you're cutting you know not not kind of
the slack not the B team but you're
cutting people out of the a team you
also want to if you possibly can let
people know that you're going to be
rehiring that you're going to want to
re-engage them but do the whole process
in a way where you've not destroyed
their loyalty their emotional connection
to the firm that means explaining why
it's happening being sure that they
understand why it's you know why certain
people not other people and if you can
giving them at least the hope that
there's a rehire when the economy starts
to tick up do all of those things and I
think you can get through a lot of the
cost cutting without an undermining the
morale and your company or without
finding that you've kind of cut off some
of the most valuable people that you've
eaten the seed corn as it were
inadvertently in the midst of a crisis
so I think you have to be very very
careful in the way you do this and you
have to recognize that recessions are
temporary we've come out of everyone you
know during our lifetimes we're going to
come out of this one and what do you
often find is the companies that had to
cut less deeply that we're able to cut a
soldier through did not lose key
resources did not you know bringing
their key capital projects to halt those
are the companies that gained market
share on the upturn because you know
what it is really hard to rehire at
least great people talented people takes
a long time to find that it bring them
back on board again make them productive
takes time to get those capital projects
underway again so if you can find ways
of cutting less deeply through the
depths of the recession you absolutely
have an advantage coming out of the
recession now it's also true that you
know some companies over higher and I
think this is usually kind of a
political thing you know in most
organizations we measure people's
authority and kind of their status by
the size of their budget and the size of
their head count so it's kind of an
imperial instinct that people have they
want bigger teams more people and so on
and so you have to keep that in check
you know you have to keep constant
attention on to all those key
productivity measures and make sure that
at no point as you grow to those things
get significantly out of whack yes you
know if you're in a fast-growing market
you're fast growing company you have to
hire a bit above you know the the demand
curve because it takes awhile to bring
people on board and get them up to speed
but you want to watch those ratios very
very carefully make sure that they never
get out of line that that that you at
every moment through the down and the up
curve that that you are paying attention
there if you stop paying attention for a
moment it's very easily for people at
all levels in the organizations to pad
their teams with more people to hire a
bit indiscriminately and then you
suddenly find out that when times are
tough again you have a lot of slack and
you're going to have to put the
organization to a lot of trauma to get
rid of that so be careful when you hire
right don't over higher but also be
careful not to over cut because coming
out of the recession the ones that have
been able to maintain kind of the
women's status the capital programs
they're going to be the quickest to ramp
up growth and grab the market as it
emerges as we come out of the recession